[Musique]
m
chers parents mon rêve depuis tout petit
la nouriture voir pour un coût
je me rappelle de nouveau ce format
grand mère a vraiment apprécié par
métallisé de fonds de la part qui lui
était réservée et carouge
malgré cette édition tels que je suis je
ne pouvais m'empêcher de pommes sa part
pour moi parce que j'étais assez moon je
ne vous connais l'astuce pour laquelle
elle a réussi à l'empêcher de prendre
son repas au deuxième on pratique l
agilité dans son assiette
sachant que les soirs et bien depuis
lors j'ai appris à me discipliner et à
manger dans l'assiette
après l'obtention de mon bac j'ai fait
les études en pharmacie
une année plus tard j'ai été remercié
[Musique]
pouvoir parce que je vais valider les
matières au cours de l'année déjà lors
de l'hymne une ferme à m
j'ai toujours dit au revoir merci je
vais donc orientée en ce que jamais sûr
le plus ce qui est de la restauration
croyez moi c'était pas facile parce
qu'il est par un désir est que je sois
reporter jamais que je partageais sur
elle en son temps j'ai fait les études
professionnelles ne trouve et où le
terrible la restauration j'ai fermé ds
où je suis sentie premier je venais dans
la filière prendre les 14 ans suivi a
poursuivi en faisant une licence
cette fois ci en tourisme hôtellerie
récit pour affronter une histoire
je vais prendre les raisons de la file
deux pays
selon professeur parfois du bec lors je
consommais part de céréales mais se
confronter de chasse de 15 de fruits et
de racines entre des chercheurs
américains tradition a les yeux
professeur avancé vide et que l'on
reconstruise dans le chien charles diers
antilles mais leurs environs dans ces
lieux d'europe en plus de démontrer que
ça qu'ils ont transformé des végétaux et
on produisait à l'occasion de la faille
[Musique]
vous seriez vous d'accord avec noir que
les caractéristiques de l'alimentation
préhistorique réside donc dans une
croissance de la consommation de serré
ce n'est qu'à partir de la naissance et
l'agriculture que les premiers levés
ancestraux feu cultivé et consommer
parlant celui effectué le petit épeautre
et puis contenir une faible teneur en
gluten environ 7 ressemblent et se plaît
ne permettait pas de farid et je faire
ou encore les pattes artificielles et
ceci va les procédures de modification
du génome et de croisement que nous
sommes arrivés à retenir les levées que
nous consommons aujourd'hui serait année
une forte teneur en gluten en plus dense
a fait savoir que la reine le fait que
la série introduit de la guerre censée
être naturel ses recteurs produit qui a
été transformée est modifié ma vie dès
lors c'est devenu nocifs pour l'homme
donc développer les arts et j ai des tas
d intolérance au gluten le week end ses
droits le pdci est une protéine
antonin d'euros tout ce qui est céréales
je dirais plutôt société céréales
notamment le blé ce qui viennent
apparaît généralement lors de il était
du paysage et de l'hydratation de la
famille wade explicite
lorsque vous prenez la mie de pain
et quand vous les croisez vos doigts
c'est le dernier dans le sud et l'est
ici d al ahly alors je me demandais je
me posais des questions comment faire
pour arriver à enfler une forme de
pétition
j'ai fait des formations qu'elle
trouvait whif et le couvent est un fils
des progressions lundi 0 initié mardi
dans le but de renforcer les capacités
des femmes dans le tour et du digital et
de notre colère de par une acidité à
l'information
j'ai obtenu ou gérer
avec au total en fait râler simpara des
nord et devient le mentor et les séances
de travail avec pièces vont conduire les
48 ma vie où je me suis demandé où je me
suis posée des personnels d'éducation
comment fuir une pâtisserie qui soirée
unique et différente de celle ci est d
un seul marché
ici à vous quels sont les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés et mieux
encore les problèmes auxquels je n'aime
particulièrement confrontés à un gros
bonnet de ma vie j'ai apporté une
mauvaise habitude alimentaire
je consommais sont de belles séries de
sucreries qui ont favorisé le jure
l'homo nation de revoir alors comment
dont jérôme seydoux soeur il fallait
donc trouver la formule magique
la formule idéale et si je réalise bon
où je trouve la formule magique au jeu
10 je fais une forme de pâtisserie du
soir calorique que la traditionnelle et
lieu encore qui soit et éthique qui
fusent et et éthiques
de par l'association de ces ingrédients
croit ferme et el materi n'est pas
évident sa demande la patience et javon
que j'apprends encore salon du travail
du travail pour sélectionner et lycées
les meilleurs fard et sans gluten
maîtriser le dosage des ingrédients et
bien sûr l'association des saveurs
[Musique]
on peut leur dire que malgré tout je
suis resté pharmacienne n'est ce pas
alors j'y mets 4 août chef pâtissière
spécialisée dans la pâtisserie sans
gluten je me permets de mettre ma tante
[Musique]
alors
cette année dans la pâtisserie son luth
elle semblait et son sucre raffiné en
disant une chose chaque bout de cannes
qui a reçu solution naturelle qui n'a
subi aucune transformation premiers
résultats obtenus à fespa son jus de la
canne à sucre ou de la soul betteraves
sucrières
auparavant le chaque usine est restée
cachée dans un physique en compagnie de
ses casseroles et lina l'entre-sort de
furies
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui le monde a progressé
tout les habitudes ont changé
il interrompt logis ont évolué et une
nouvelle ère elle parle
les chiens sont provenus de long pour
révolutionner la planète
cette nouvelle mode dans les amis pour
qu'ils sauvent ou mémoire devenons de
plus en plus exigeants en matière de
goûts les textures des saveurs et de
qualité du produit
cette fois le pâtissier rick est très
développé aux états unis ou encore en or
mais il y avait une grande fierté que je
peux dire qu'on vénère nous pouvons
consommer de la pâtisserie
tél nous pouvons prendre des poissons
des chinoiseries des pizzas qui sont
fait sembler et aussi du fun fait à base
de farine de manioc de plantes et aux
empreintes de pattes à tous alors vive
la révolution univers confiné et gilles
la tradition dit elle j'aimerais rester
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]